Welcome back. So there you have it. That's goal setting. That's our first look at it.
We looked at the 90-day goals. We looked at the top five goals. It's important to know when going through this.
The first time I'm going through this, just get it done. Doesn't have to be perfect.
Because every 90 days we review how we're doing with these goals. We check them out. We see, okay, we're doing well here.
We're struggling a bit here. And it helps us have what we call a gap analysis.
Where we can see, okay, what we forecast, where we want to go, and what do we actually achieve.
And that helps us gauge where we can improve at the end of the day.
So when I used to go with my clients doing this, it would be every 90 days we do a 90-day goal review.
And we'll be looking at that coming up in the future. And when we do that review, we're going to unpack it systematically.
Okay, how we're doing and so forth. And we make little adjustments in calibration.
It was the famous boxer, Floyd Mayweather, who said, okay, you may hit harder than me.
You may be faster than me, but nobody calibrates better than me. And that was his claim to fame.
That's why he believed he was such a world champion boxer. Because he's always making microcalibrations and adjustments.
Well, it's exactly the same thing when we're doing our goal setting.
We come back after the 90 days, we check out how we're going, same with the weekly goals, the top five.
We see how we're doing, we make calibrations, and then we improve and we grow from there.
So enjoy, and I'll see you in the next session. Ciao.